your drink is filled to the brim you are
celebrating already Blake as usual you
have two performers in the finale how
are you feeling heading into the final
hurray
I'm excited I mean these these both of
these artists I think either one of them
could win the thing I mean odds on uh
Grace because she's a country artist you
know and country artists do
so well on the show she's the only one
left so I think
uh that probably gives her a little bit
of an advantage over the entire field
but but Nueva also I think people hear
him and seem and they think of him as as
country also and I told him that you
know I go man I go I think people think
of you as country so I mean you're kind
of the the the wild card here so I would
not be surprised to see him win the
thing too I'm excited for about for both
of them really double the chance of
winning out here speaking of chances
actually chance said that he thinks
you're out here pulling strings and he's
like a producer or something so if
anything goes Haywire just know Blake
did cheat for sure yeah I you know
chance says a lot of stuff that's just
not true and he's he's lacking in
credibility in in the truth Department
uh you know I don't I don't know uh I've
I'll do whatever it takes from for my
team to win so maybe there is some truth
to string pulling you are heading out
with a bang in the finale we've got a
star-studded lineup including Adam
Levine coming back to send you off how
do you feel about that I think that's
the only bad idea that the producers
have had you know because everything
else feels like exciting and we're you
know we're looking forward to it as a as
a team and a crew here that work on the
show and then they say Adam's coming
back and everybody's like well you know
can't be perfect I guess you know but we
made room for him and it'll be fine I I
hope they don't let him talk you know I
I think he's a great singer he's just a
he's just a crappy coach you know no
talking just singing Adam how will Gwen
and the boys celebrate your final time
here on The Voice actually I shouldn't
say final because maybe we can get you
back as a mentor when Gwen's back but
how will going to the boys be
celebrating you
well I think you know I've had enough uh
parties thrown for me in the last couple
of weeks you know Gwen said she goes you
know that whole Hollywood uh uh star
things he goes it's all kind of this
we're just celebrating you you're good
right I go yeah I'm good please no more
parties for me but I I bet the family is
excited to have you home more more
family time and that's really what
especially this next chapter is going to
be like for you right it is for me you
know I mean I I want to to finally have
the opportunity to to just say yes to a
bunch of stuff in my personal life and
not let me check or or just flat out
know you know so I'm I'm super excited
about that part
[Music]